quel regard porte en historien sur la
campagne présidentielle que nous vivons
actuellement
réponse avec christian delporte
professeur à l'université de
versailles-saint-quentin question ne
porte bonjour merci de nous recevoir
dans la bibliothèque du centre
d'histoire culturelle des sociétés
contemporaines que vous dirigez vous
êtes professeur à l'université de
versailles saint quentin vous ce genre
d'histoire contemporaine
vous avez consacré plusieurs ouvrages à
la communication politique
une histoire de la langue de bois l
histoire de la séduction aux politiques
notamment
alors j'ai vraiment votre regard
d'historien sur l'actualité déjà la
campagne présidentielle qui se déroule
est ce qu'elle vous fait penser à des
campagnes passées ou est ce que c'est
une campagne sujet des risques on
pourrait dire évidemment elle ressemble
beaucoup à la campagne de 1981 parce
qu'il y a un président sortant en
exercice je dis bien en exercice
pleinement on exhorte puisque ça n'était
pas le cas par exemple de françois
mitterrand en 1988 chirac ni chirac en
2002 alors évidemment il ya une
situation totalement inédite puisque
lorsque
giscard se présente en 1981 il est le
favori des sondages aujourd'hui on a une
situation complètement inverse où le
favori est l'homme de l'opposition et
challenger le président en exercice mais
il ya également des des éléments juste
deux éléments qui me surprennent un
petit peu c'est d'abord la longueur de
la campagne mis bout-à-bout entre les
précampagnes comment elle a pratiquement
un an alors qu autrefois campagne
électorale c'était quatre mois à cinq
mois et puis il ya la question de
l'ambiance vous avez remarqué qu'il n'y
a pas dans les rues de grandes affiches
électorales puisque maintenant ça n'est
plus possible ça n'est plus possible
depuis des douanes des années 1990 et en
revanche il y à de multiples supports
d'information de la campagne des chaînes
de télévision et aux radios et puis
internet joue un rôle considérable
est ce que on est en train d'assister
justement un gros changement c'est vrai
qu'ils avaient ces grandes affiches
voilà et charbon 14 on envoyait dans
toutes les rues ça change aussi la façon
de faire de la politique ça oui parce
qu'en fait on fait uniquement de la
politique bat tous pour la télévision
regardez les meetings électoraux ils
sont conçus uniquement pour la
télévision la preuve c'est que les
candidats
sarkozy l'a fait en 2007
oldelaf et en 2012 au bourget ont leurs
propres images tournent leurs propres
images qu'ils proposent aux télévisions
est divisé en fait diffuser images qui
ont été prises par les parties parlées
connu d'importants problèmes à
l'information ça on est dans la
communication
bien sûr on a vu une fois le mythique de
hollande par exemple qu'il reprend une
proposition qui avait été convaincue par
martine aubry lors des primaires il n'y
a pas de plans sur martine aubry par
exemple
non il me répond faire
journaliste évidemment c'est de la com
c'est de la mise en scène
ça veut évidemment de belles images live
sans bavure grandi elles sont très
favorables elles sont sans doute moins
figée que ce qu'on a l'habitude de voir
et donc ça même du beau spectacle et la
télévision a besoin de spectacle
je reviens à ce que vous disiez sur la
longueur de la campagne présidentielle
est ce que c'est en rapport ou pas avec
le quinquennat
le fait que le ton est plus court est
vrai mais que la contrainte du coup un
peu plus l'eau est sans doute sans doute
et nous ce point de vue d'ailleurs ça
nous rappelle les campagnes américaines
qu'il a au lieu de quatre en quatre
heures est pratiquement pendant un an la
dernière année du monde à grands pas
j'aime c'est une campagne des primaires
avec wii donc donc ça ça joue évidemment
faire le raccourcissement du mandat
présidentiel d'où sur la longueur de la
compagne dans l'est alors là évidemment
on vous dit tout à l'heure il ya plus le
favori a changé c'est plus en plus
présent en place alors on a tendance à
reconstruire comme ça un petit peu
l'histoire des campagnes présidentielles
en disant aux foules favoris ne gagnent
jamais est ce que c'est vrai parce que
c'est ce qu'il faut d'humour c'est ça
alors savais pas à quel moment on est
favori c'est quand on est favori à
l'automne on va nous gagne pas toujours
à l'arrivée en revanche vous avez état
de campagne en campagne
ça se confirme il ya un moment où on ne
sait pas vraiment pourquoi l'électorat
se cristallise et grosso modo on le sait
parce que maintenant nous sommes quand
même un neuvième campagne préférée quand
c'est trop c'est comme ça ce se
cristallisent y lire entre le 15 janvier
et le 15 février
parfois en 2007 les jeux étaient faits
le 15 janvier rien juste après le sport
du manger
le batteur de versailles de sarkozy 295
les jeux étaient faits du côté du 15
février c'est lorsque chirac était passé
deux bonnes occasions l'inversé voilà et
après et bien après l'électorat est
tellement cristallisé que les choses ne
bougent pas au cou ce qui explique
d'ailleurs pourquoi la campagne bat son
plein en 2012 en janvier ou début
février
donc vous pensez la drs cristallisé très
vite donc maintenant tout est possible
c'est justement cet historien que
j'avais cette question parce que est ce
qu'on n'a pas tendance à leur guise
c'est aussi le rôle de l'historien b2 de
refaire l'histoire
à partir de ce conseil à partir des
résultats qu'elle a donnée c'est à dire
par exemple on dit voilà balladur en 95
a fait une campagne épouvantable il
n'aurait pas dû se présenter en
annonçant sa candidature de matignon se
comportait comme de la personne qui
exerçait le pouvoir mais on reconstruit
des choses après est ce que on
reconstruit tellement que on trouve
formidable le slogan de la force
tranquille alors que pendant la campagne
ce slogan arrivant très tardivement dans
la campagne de mitterrand
personne ne l'avait remarqué bon et
comme il a gagné c'est devenu un
expérience legault et même un modèle non
c'est vrai que ce que je vous dis sur la
cristallisation de l'électorat s'est pas
jugement de valeur c'est à leur constat
statistique scientifique
on le voit et on le voit se répéter
finalement et même on me donne toujours
en contre-exemple 2002 mais en 2002 du
côté du 15 février
les hiérarchies sont établis chirac
étant au suivi de jospin et ensuite les
nomades et ce qui se passe en fait il
sait que dans la dernière phase c'est
que le pen rattrape et dépasse jospin
justement sur sur ces histoires de ses
compagnes de lectra est-ce que
encore une fois c'est historique se bat
pas ce qu'est ce qu'elle est une qui
vous paraît au fond plus plus plus
intéressante que les autres dans celle
qu'on a pu vivre dans les compagnies
talent de la vème république
les campagnes les plus intéressantes
c'est quand les hommes paraissent hommes
et les femmes apparaissent 9 lorsqu'il
ya un véritable enjeu est de ce point de
vue la campagne de 2007
c'est effectivement très intéressant et
est la moins intéressante finalement ça
a été la campagne de 2002 d'abord elle à
elle un résultat qu'on attendait pas
d'essuyer un cadeau un peu pitoyable
mais c'est à ça et surtout les candidats
se sont déclarés très tardivement ne
semblait pas avoir beaucoup de
propositions et la campagne va
enthousiasmer personnes il suffisait de
voir le visage des militants dans les
meetings pour savoir que la flamme
n'était pas là vous disiez justement
2007 il y eut comme ça et une ferveur
populaire très forte une croyance dans
la politique
est ce que vous direz qu elle est
retombée impôts aujourd'hui présent la
deux le fait que la politique au fond et
à l'idée c'est que les gens politiques
ne peuvent plus rien elle n'est pas très
neuf
elle l'a déjà en place à la fin des
années 80 est précisément en 2007 on a
cru que les hommes politiques pouvaient
faire quelque chose que le politique
dominée notamment l'économique
stelmach discours de m on veut on peut
en gros voilà c'est ça et cette vague là
est retombé ce que l'on peut craindre en
c'est que cette déception se traduisent
notamment par une abstention beaucoup
plus forte y avait une participation
considérable en 2007
il m'étonnerait beaucoup qu'on la
retrouve en 2012 là il ya évidemment la
une campagne qui est assez symbolique
c'est celle de 80 parce que là il ya
vraiment on a l'impression qu'il ya un
choix de société change d'avis et 74 mo
fargo pourrait le reprendre 80 pour
mitterrand on
une société où les choses ont beaucoup
changé de ce produit la wii en 1981 ça a
été un grand moment parce que c'était la
première fois que la gauche arrive au
pouvoir
mais c'est également parce que la gauche
était persuadée qu'elle n'y
parviendraient jamais par la présidence
de la république puisque ce régime avec
un voisin garder le pouvoir à droite
évidemment les choses ont beaucoup
changé jurent les rêves se sont
considérablement affaissé les clivages
idéologiques ne sont plus aussi fort que
quand 1980 mais il me semble quand même
qu'il y à un climat toujours particulier
dans une campagne électorale et quand
même si on dit que on ne croit pas aux
promesses où on ne croit pas au rêve
eh bien il ya toujours un petit moment
où on a envie d'y croire parce que tout
simplement on veut croire dans l'avenir
vous avez réalisé ya quelque temps un
documentaire très passionnant sur la sur
la façon de s'exprimer de françois
mitterrand on dit beaucoup que la force
de françois hollande de parler notamment
tribune dans les meetings ressemble
beaucoup à celle de françois mitterrand
vous voyez des points en commun
oui ça n'est pas faux ce n'est pas faux
d'abord parce que françois hollande est
un bon orateur il y avait beaucoup de
bons orateurs dans la vie politique
française tout simplement parce que
télévision la télévision changer les
choses parce que les meetings ne sont
plus maintenant au centre d'une campagne
ça va casser pour les jambes une et
pagayant le seul bon orateur sur la
place politique mais on n'en on est
attiré par la manière dont françois
hollande parle au meeting on le
rapproche de mitterrand tout simplement
parce qu'il est le candidat socialiste
mais mais dans les attitudes bien sûr
mais en fait ça a toujours été un bon
orateur et s'est toujours inspiré de
françois mitterrand qui a qui a marqué
effectivement le le parti socialiste
c'est vrai on voit dans son attitude
dans la manière de
d'agiter la main dans cette manière
également de sur le cul pitre au on voit
effectivement des déjà et puis également
dans l'art de la fosse improvisation car
quand mitterrand venait à une tribune il
n'avait pas de discours écrit il avait
quelques idées qu'ils avaient tracé là
sur une feuille blanche avec son fameux
waterman à encre bleue et il brode est
sûre sur cette idée là et remarqué les
orateurs aujourd'hui ils ont de plus en
plus de mal à se dégager de leurs notes
et le bon orateur c'est celui qui semble
en tout cas parler sans notes
ce qui est important aujourd'hui quand
même c'est pour conclure cette première
partie d'un entretien la télévision
internet dont on parlait tout à l'heure
c'est quand même plus important que les
meetings
non ça va quand même ça n'est pas plus
important que les meetings ça n'est pas
plus important que le porte à porte mais
il n'empêche que il y à un lieu où les
gens s'informent et ça les sondages nous
le disent quand on leur demande quel est
le principal outil pour s'informer il
répond toujours toujours la télévision
et tout le reste est fait pour la
télévision regarder les meetings les
mythes y sont construits pour ça il
suffit de voir comment sont installés
dans la salle les différents
protagonistes de ce spectacle qu'est
devenu un meeting
merci beaucoup les portes je pense qu'on
se retrouve pour continuer à parler de
la durant garden historiens sur la vie
politique avec plaisir